- [Narrator] This is Olivia,
an East African Crowned Crane.
She is stunning.
She stands about four feet tall
with a wingspan of six and a half feet.
Her legs are long and slender,
perfect for wading through grassy areas.
Mostly gray, the wings
are predominantly white
with a range of colors,
while her head is full of golden feathers.
East African Crowned Cranes are well-known
for their elaborate dancing.
These cranes are omnivores,
eating everything from plants to insects,
snakes, small fish, and more.
Native to eastern sub-Saharan Africa,
and down to South Africa,
they prefer living in
grassland areas near the water.
The Crowned Crane is the
national bird of Uganda,
featured on its flag.
But even with such iconic
status, we're losing them.
In less than 10 years,
their population has
decreased by over 50%.
Habitat loss and illegal removal
of eggs and birds from the
wild are its biggest threats.
This is the East African Crowned Crane.
(gentle, inspirational music)